hello grammarians so today we're going
to talk about the third and final
function of the colon so this final
function of the colon is that it can be
used as a separator so it might sound
like we're talking about the comma again
right the comma separates elements of a
sentence but the colon does it in kind
of a different way so let's look at some
examples so one common use of the colon
as a separator is in titles so you can
have two separate parts of the title or
like a title and a subtitle for a book
or a movie or a TV show and there will
be a colon in between them we can have
something like bear man adventures in
Alaska another common use of the colon
as a separator is in citations from a
book or a poem and pretty often the
Bible for example we can use it to
separate the number of a Bible chapter
from the number of the verse if we want
to reference first Corinthians chapter
13 verse 4 we can write it like 1
Corinthians 13 colon 4 finally we can
use the colon to separate the hour from
the minutes in the time of day if I want
to tell someone what time it is I can
say it is now
10:09 a.m. and between the 10 which is
the hour of the day and oh 9 which is
the minutes we put a colon
so that's how the colon works as a
separator we can use it in titles
citations and times you can learn
anything
page out